welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with a new
Candyman film right around the corner
it's time to dive into who the character
really is throughout this video we're
gonna be breaking down everything you
need to know about the Candyman
including the characters history origins
and what could be happening in the new
film as the new movie is a direct sequel
to the first entry we will mainly be
covering that but there will be a couple
of tidbits here and there on the series
as a whole obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything about the franchise ruined then
I highly suggest that you go and say
Jeremy Jones five times in a mirror to
get a spoiler free review of the movie
or something anyway with all that out of
the way thanks for clicking the video we
love you Jeremy now let's get into our
breakdown of Candyman Candyman the urban
legend is if you say his name five times
by looking in the mirror he appears in
the reflection and it kills you okay so
Candyman was actually created by Clive
Barker and a short story called the
forbidden this piece was part of a
collection by the British author called
the books of blood there are over six
volumes all containing different stories
and works and several of them have been
adapted into live-action films including
raw head Rex the Lord of illusions
Quicksilver Highway and many more
however the forbidden or rather Candyman
as it would later come to be known in
its on-screen depiction is by far the
most famous of the stories the short
story follows Helen a university student
that is in the process of writing a
thesis on graffiti she slowly uncovers
the myth after discovering some that
makes reference to an urban legend known
as the Candyman the locals in the area
refused to discuss what this means and
she begins to investigate what's really
going on which leads to her becoming a
victim of the character the film itself
roughly follows this framework but it
adds a lot in changes of several
elements of it especially the ending in
the book the other character was
described as smelling like candy floss
his race and the mentioning of his name
in a mirror were all completely absent
instead in the original source material
just doubting that he existed cause the
character to come forth we know how
things have changed since then
and the villain was massively fleshed
out in the film adaptation in the movie
we discovered that Candyman was the son
of a slave who after being set free
developed a way to mass-produce shoes
during the Civil War
because of this his father became very
rich and Candy Man aka Daniel grew up in
high society though he was well
respected in the area in 1890 after he
fathered a child with a white woman he
was set upon by a mob hired by a father
and brutally killed they cut off his
right hand and smeared him with honey so
that bees would sting him to death later
in the series we learned that the gang
that carry this out chanted Candyman
five times and this is where the
summoning sprung from in the film itself
we join Helen discovering cabrini-green
which is where the characters ashes were
scattered after he was burned in a pyre
since his death he has become a vengeful
spirit that terrorizes the area and this
drives the main plot of the movie Tony
Todd who plays the character came up
with the majority of this backstory June
rehearsals and this really fleshed out
the racial subtext that is now a
mainstay within the franchise in the
film after several run-ins Helen makes a
deal with the Candyman in order to spare
the life of a baby during a bonfire
Candyman appears and Helen manages to
save the baby Anthony whilst the
antagonists perishes in the fire Helen
too succumbs to her wounds and the movie
ends with her taking up the mantle and
becoming a vengeful spirit herself so
there is this theme of Candyman passing
on his legacy to others and I'll get
into this later when we talk about how
the movie could be continuing this
aesthetic I've always viewed the
character as a sort of antihero and in
some ways to me he's keeping the memory
of himself alive to remind others of the
darker side of humanity the axe that
happened to Candyman were horrible and
not uncommon at the time and the
character has always for me served as a
reminder of the dangers of prejudice
initially in the source material he
killed those that doubted his existence
in order to keep his name alive and this
is very much repeated and built upon in
the film adaptations Candyman is
summoned by saying its name five times
in a mirror and obviously no one would
want to be killed in such a brutal way
so the fact that they feel comfortable
doing this shows they don't really
believe in the character and therefore
he returns the killings are often pinned
innocent person who just so happened to
be at the scene and thus police never
looked too closely at the murders candy
man's victims on the whole having
arrogance to them like they are more
real than the legends that circulate and
the villain shows that we must not be
arrogant in shutting things down
and dismissing the past Tony Todd is
liking the character to several of those
in pop culture including the DC Comics
villain Scarecrow both rely on fear and
the allure of it and he has stated that
there are many similarities however
other comparisons have been drawn up and
many consider Candyman to be similar to
a vampire most notably Dracula Dracula
can appear to be a handsome man and
there are facets of his personality that
paint him out as a tortured artist and
hopeless romantic
both use seduction in order to gather
their victims and there are a wealth of
similarities between Candyman and the
myths and legends of our world the first
film is great and I was expecting it to
have aged poorly but after re-watching
it recently I must say that I did enjoy
it whilst the other entries different
quality I definitely recommend that you
go and check out that first entry if you
are all interested in the franchise
it'll get you fully up to speed with a
new release and it also hints at what
could be happening in that the trailer
for Candyman showcases that the movie
follows photographer Anthony McCoy as he
begins to unearth the legend of the
titular character
Anthony is actually baby Anthony from
the first film all grown up and similar
to how Helen became part of the legend
he may of to the movie also features his
mother played by the same actress who
hasn't really aged and it's got me
thinking maybe she's her own legend
anyway we see that the legend is alive
and well and several girls in a bathroom
do the hashtag Candyman challenge which
ultimately leads to their deaths another
girl also enters the bathroom and this
continues the aesdirect that's someone
innocent tends to take the blame for the
killings the movie is also set to the
backdrop of the gentrification of
Chicago gentrification is basically a
process in which a run-down neighborhood
is rebuilt and repurposed through the
influx of more middle-class businesses
and residents in order to try and
attract wealthy clientele so whilst the
film is set in the same area as the
first movie it does look like things
have changed at the location Anthony
trying to exploit the legend of
man without understanding the true
history of the myth could be a comment
on how gentrification exploits an area
for gain without truly understanding the
turmoil that went on there there's a lot
of subtext to it that I'm sure will be
fleshed out in the film and it looks
like this will be laced with the wealth
of social commentary
Anthony dares several characters in the
film to say candy man's name and he also
holds an art exhibit that is full of
mirrors and reflective surfaces slowly
Candyman Rises but it is possible that
there is a reason why he seems to become
Anthony later in the trailer now as we
know from Helen it is possible for
people to become their own Candyman in a
way and this is likely what's happening
here Anthony's mother does say that
Candyman could be after him and it is
possible that he has his eyes set on the
character in the hopes that he becomes
another one of his terrible stories
however I actually have another theory
that I think lines up with the trailer
now it is possible that due to the
gentrification of Chicago that the
character has become a lot we care
Candyman is very much tied to the
location in several ways and he is a
figure that is specific to the area thus
when it is changed and remodeled his
powers go with it because of this I
believe he has to strike through others
and in the trailer with the girls scene
we do see a reflection of Candyman in
which he wears a similar coat to one of
the girls the fact that he also seems to
be possessing Anthony and this is shown
through a mirror could show that he is
instead living within him and using him
as a vessel to strike others and then he
catches himself in a reflection and sees
that the hook is indeed one's hand
appears to be we also see that his hand
itself is damaged and this could be from
earlier in the trailer in which he was
stung by a bee either way Anthony is
clearly carrying on the legend of the
character through his artwork and
spreading the news of Candyman thus
allowing his legend - once more
reimagined take over the area overall
it's no surprise that Candyman has
lasted for decades and he's one of the
most unique horror figures of all time
I'm very excited to see the film and
I'll be doing a full update on the
Candyman after it releases to let you
know all of the additional information
that we learn on the character through
the new entry now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on Candyman and if
you're excited for the new film let me
know your thoughts on the theories and
what you think will be revealed when it
releases I was actually worried about
making this video
because I'm staring into a highly
reflective screen and saying candy man
so much but yeah it's been you know okay
so absorb sorry that that's the worst
way end of video ever anyway please drop
a like if you enjoyed everything other
than that terrible joke
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of some insane details we
noticed in Captain America Civil War
after binge watching the Infinity Saga I
guarantee you haven't seen some of them
so definitely get that watch every month
on the 15th would give away free
blu-rays and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning the Infinity
Saga box set is leave a like and
subscribe with notifications on you want
to support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button you can also
come chat to us on our discord server
link below or at definition YT on
Twitter those are the best ways to keep
up to date with the channel so hopefully
we see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe a huge thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best now
see you next time take care peace